yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing zoton zoton not so dumb whatever
any form so T form D for opening let's
see what we get yeah this is not the
best against Queen B 3 I believe I had
not that I'm totally certain but hey
maybe actually my c5 is a bit early but
okay it didn't really test that
something like Queen c7 maybe asking me
about Bishop f4 anyway
I'm I'm quite okay with such a position
him
my idea is to play b5 if possible maybe
I could have done it actually okay now
he's prevented to send him it's still
quite comfortable I have a very
straightforward idea night D 2 B 3 a 5
and he has to go with the quick
a bishop to d8 in order to cover a 5 or
sometimes sometimes black gets a decent
position by playing like g5 Bishop g7
and a quickie five it doesn't look like
it and it seems like he's going for the
bishop e78 plan you know now Bishop to
the 8th
and yeah you got you can you have a
choice you can grab the bishop pair by
means of 95 1 you can play let him play
Bishop c7 I'm going for the bishop pal
now both captures make some sense
actually hmm what do we do them they
both make some sense I'm taking with the
pawn it's it's a tough call
yep okay I should not take this of
course and ruin my porn structure and
maybe maybe maybe there was there was a
lot there was a bit of a point now to
take okay maybe in this particular case
I could have taken yeah anyway so the
main drawback for white in such a
position is the default partner that is
a bit weak but this is a good maneuver
look to be form covers deform and at the
same time put some pressure on b7
okay not so clear what black spline is
in this balloon we want to go to a
seven-year with the rook oh my goodness
that looks suit okay maybe you have to
do it but it doesn't really feel very
nice
okay night is coming to e6
okay everything is nicely coordinated
but how do we how do we win them now how
do we win from this position I could the
knight on c3 is an interesting piece
does not do that much knight Knight to
f4 in order to trade a six could be an
idea that only six assists is a more
active piece at the moment attacking
deform or I could just put this on to b6
and just say okay yeah this Lukas never
moving again that's a tough call William
that's a tough tough one let's do this
but I'm not certain one of those cases
where there's multiple
there are things there's more than one
thing that looks promising ninety-seven
okay
so it's at the right moment for g4
business you can actually first of all I
put this here G 4 F 4 F 5 this kind of
thing
yeah it's not exactly easy for black to
make a move so ah that was the idea
interesting but if I take now this is a
that's a good way to Chintu to do it
wait um not so easy in the F pawn an
asset a problem I can go to d8 okay
[Music]
let's go to d8 simplex rooks are far
funny
the a a seven book is really funny
okay now how do we play this f4 rugae
three is made you know
[Music]
that's a very enjoyable game to play
I always like it if they cannot move so
yeah sometimes games this line produces
games like this it's not very uncommon
that was a very very nice one one
interesting thing that I learned over
the years is that it is actually quite a
good idea for black if you don't rename
I mean you don't have to do it but it is
not a terrible idea to simply take the
night because it's very difficult to
make blacks Bishop a good Bishop ever
that the bishop that does something and
this kind of structure is extremely
solid 1976 g6 Bishop g7 everything on
light squares it's not such a bad idea
okay it's not like this was a huge
mistake or so but I'm just saying taking
on b1 is an idea yeah and it's that what
it really looked awful
yeah you're just sitting there maybe as
I said maybe taking was an option I
didn't really pay attention there
because I was just playing the automatic
moves but I mean this is it's not so
clear how he gets his stuff back at
something like this it's not so
self-evident how that is good for for
black the engine wants to return the
pawn immediately like this I mean the
weird thing is that somehow I have no
development but it's possible that white
is still better
I mean his pieces are really not very
active maybe they don't do much okay
Knight h2 is yeah like the autopilot
more in this position is just bad for
like I mean you can know whatever you if
you have to do this it's a disaster
yeah I'm just doing the like normal
things
this is just this is anticipating a
later f/4g for you you want to be in a
better position there on d6 and yeah it
just looks awful yeah night Knight b6
immediately it's even stronger yeah
that's a huge double attack yeah that's
you know that this wins even quicker
well what is he supposed to play now I
am absolutely but this is this is also
when you cannot hold this position I
mean that is just too too weird yeah now
you just get the rook backend
f4 was good just already but yeah that's
it's obviously very you have many uh
okay I could have checkmated in with
rook d6 yeah I didn't see it dead
multiple checkmates I just saw that I
win everything
yeah it's it's a lot of material then
this is this position type in this
position type him that can't come up
from different move orders you can get
it from some London systems and then
from this and there are even in some
cases where black is a temple up on that
on this particular line and even then it
doesn't make much it's not much fun okay
thanks for watching